this phrase if what doesn't get you in
the rinse will get you what doesn't get
you in the wash will get you in the
rinse this applies to a video that's
just gone
viral from the porn actress Mia Khalifa
don't worry you don't necessarily need
to take your children out of the room if
they're watching this right now it's not
it's not one of those videos this woman
goes viral all the time for political
reasons which I guess is better
than presumably her other vide on the
internet I don't know though actually
because the content of her political
activism is so awful that I I can only
imagine what her actual obscene content
looks like Mia Khalifa has gone viral in
this case not for her Pro terrorism
activism but because she was recounting
a very ugly incident that happened to
her at a restaurant here in her own
words and I get come up to by this guy
and his girlfriend and we were
interrupted in the middle of talking and
eating and he said hey Mia CIFA can I
get a picture with you and I looked up
at him and I'm like no we're eating and
I said it just like that like it was it
was a rude way but it was also very rude
for him to come up while someone was
actively in the middle of a conversation
and after I said that his girlfriend who
was standing next to him grabbed him by
the arm and said I told you that wasn't
her there's not enough on her face let's
go babe and I went into the bathroom and
cried and I didn't really know how to
handle it especially cuz it came from a
woman and especially because I was I
like I was I was there for business and
it was something that had nothing to do
with the adult industry and I was just
very dejected and embarrassed and felt
like they they would never want to work
with me again that must have been really
I kind of feel bad for Mia Khalifa here
now obviously every single person
involved in this story is just terrible
just everyone involved here is doing
something wrong and disreputable but I I
feel bad for it that's a really nasty
thing to I mean first of all as she says
it was the woman so think about how many
things had to go wrong for this
situation to take
place a guy would walk up to a porn
performer in
public and admit that he watches
pornography so degrading so creepy so
weird the guy would do it it in front of
his
girlfriend and she's apparently okay
with it so weird so depraved so creepy
and then the girlfriend is the one who
makes the obscene comment at the porn
lady now Mia Khalifa admits she says I
was very rude to them they come up to me
they ask for a picture they're fans I
guess and they're willing to admit that
then I was rude to them that was wrong
she shouldn't do that if anyone is going
to come up to you and be nice to you and
compliment you in public you you ought
to be gracious about that that's a good
thing to do and then what they were rude
back to her and she was upset by this
because she felt shame
because they pointed out that she's a a
hooker and and they
described the shameful actions that she
boasts about and and publicizes and that
they are so
um encouraging of that they would that
they would actually approach this woman
in public and talk about how great it is
but the moment that they became hostile
toward one another the the
gal pointed out the shameful acts that
this girl does and the girl felt shame
for those shameful
acts what doesn't get you in the wash
will get you in the
rinse believe it or not even in
the year of Our Lord 2024 even in modern
society actions still have
consequences what she's really upset
about she says she's upset that a woman
would say this to her in public what
she's really upset about is the the
shame of prostituting herself and
degrading herself and and treating
herself she's a human being with a soul
made in the image and likeness of God
treating herself is nothing but flesh to
be transformed into glitter pixels on a
screen that can then be that can then
incite the lusts of men and women
apparently and and and become fodder for
other shameful sexual
acts that's what really bothers her but
she can't admit that even if she's
speaking openly and vulnerably about
this she she can't admit that we can't
admit in our culture that actions have
consequences and so we're always
surprised we're always surprised when we
we reap what we sow and when we're
talking about
politics there's that great line from HL
Menin which is that democracy is the
theory that the common people know what
they want and deserve to get it good and
hard and we're shocked we're shocked
when the totally predictable results of
our
actions turn out to
be true wow shocking totally what what
what else did we expect China seems to
be pretty bullish on Trump's chances in
2024 the Chinese state-run newspaper the
global times just came out and told the
world this was before the Iowa caucuses
actually to quote prepare for the
possibility of Donald Trump being
reelected as president and you might say
well this is propaganda if you don't
like Trump you probably say see China is
pulling for Trump though they're not
really pulling for him they're just
saying there's a real chance the guy's
going to be reelected
and that might be the case foreigners
sometimes have a better sense of our
politics than we do I remember back in
2016 Vladimir Putin America's foe
Vladimir Putin came out and he he said
in in the early days of the primary he
said there's no question Donald Trump is
the leader in the Republican race and I
thought oh that's crazy propaganda or
he's just trying to get in our heads or
he's completely misreading the situation
this was back when all the really smart
people thought Trump didn't have a
chance but Putin was
right which makes sense I mean you'd
think that the dictator of a nuclear
reformer superpower might have a little
bit of insight into politics a guy who
came up as a KGB communist in the Soviet
Union he he probably understands a
little bit about politics probably more
than your average keyboard Warrior
pundit he was right and China might be
right here too the reason that
foreigners sometimes have better insight
into our politics than we do is the same
reason that you have great insight into
all of your friends problems don't you
you you have really really good Insight
me too we all we have really good
insight into all of our friends problems
and everything that they're doing wrong
and everything that they're missing but
we don't have quite as much insight into
our own problems do we no that's a
mystery we're befuddled by that put in a
pithier way and a more profound way
we're really good at seeing the speck in
our neighbor eye we're not so good at
seeing the plank in our own eye and I
think that's what's going on here I
don't think China is running this
headline because they're really eager
for Trump to get back in the driver seat
don't forget before covid we were in the
midst of a trade war with China and we
were winning contrary to what the Smart
Set said would happen man what a great
clip that was now hold up you got to
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nolles YouTube channel now now please
pretty please thank you appreciate that
see you next time